موجز لي اهم الانباء من قناه الجزيره في
قطر اهلا بكم
انا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
على الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين اتخذا
خطوات فوريه لتهدئه ووقف التصعيد واكدب في
مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو النحل الدولتين اساسيون
لان اسرائيل على المدى الطويل
في الاثناء اعتبرت الحكومه الفلسطينيه ان
الاجراءات والتهديدات الاسرائيليه تهدف
الى تقويض السلطه
والاداره الامريكيه بوضع اليات مرزمه توفر
الحمايه للفلسطينيين وبادانه تصريحات
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين التي تدعو لارتكاب
مزيد من الجرائم
قال مسؤول ايرانيون الجزيره ان المؤشرات
الاوليه تشير الى ضلوع اسرائيل في الهجوم
على منشاه عسكريه في اصفهان واضاف ان
الهجوم لم يكن ناجحا وانت تصريحات المصادر
الاسرائيليه مجردوا دعايه
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان سياسه حكومته هي منع ايران من
الحصول على سلاح النووي واضاف خلال مؤتمر
صحفي مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
ان اسرائيل والولايات المتحده تعملان معا
لتحقيق هذا الهدف المشترك
ووصفت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الهجوم على
مصنع عسكري في ايران بالاستفزازي ونقلت
وكاله رويترز عن الخارجيه الروسيه قولها
ان مثل هذه التصرفات المدمره قد تكون لها
تبعات غير متوقعه على السلام والاستقرار
في الشرق الاوسط
قال رئيس الامريكي
لن تزود اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16
لاحد الصحفيين عما اذا كانت واشنطن ستزود
كيف بالمقاتلات
فقط ان بلاده لم تتلقى طلباز بتسليمها
طائرات مقاتله واكد انه في حال طلبه
اوكرانيا ذلك فان فرنسا لا تستبعد القيامه
باي شيء بدعمها لكن وفقه شروط
لو قال رئيس الوزراء الفرلندي ماتيوش مورا
بيتسكي ان اي قرار بارسال طائرات اف 16
الى اوكرانيا سيتم بتنسيق كامل مع دول
ارتفع عدد قتلى تفجير الانتحاري في بيشاور
شمال غرب باكستان الى 90 وقعت تفجير في
مسجد المجاور للمقر الرئيسي لقياده الشرطه
اثناء التجمع المصلين لاداء صلاه الظهر
امثله اثنين ودعاء رئيس الحكومه برفقه
قائد الجيش الى التبرع بالدم
انتهى المجاز الى اللقاء